This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Future historians who want to learn about the 21st century will probably not lack for primary sources. As of today, approximately 30,000 hours of content are being uploaded to YouTube every hour, while Wikipedia is currently home to roughly 55 million articles and counting. For historians who want to study the previous century, the sources thin out just a bit. Archives provide access to about 2,000 daily US newspapers and another 2,000 magazines. Go back to the late Middle Ages, before the invention of the printing press, and things get a lot rougher.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。未来的历史学家如果想要了解 21 世纪，大概不会缺乏一手资料。截至今天，YouTube 每小时上传的内容大约有 3 万小时，而维基百科目前大约有 5500 万篇文章，而且还在不断增加。对于想要研究上个世纪的历史学家来说，资料就稍微变少了一点。档案库里大约有每天 2000 份的美国报纸以及另外 2000 本杂志。回到印刷术发明之前的文艺复兴晚期中世纪，情况就会变得糟糕得多。
Only a few thousand hand-copied manuscripts from that time have survived. And as for the very ancient past, the situation is downright bleak. Of the over 100 plays written by Sophocles, we have seven. But the hardest stuff to find, the further back you go, are the documents that tell us something about everyday life, about what it was like to be a bureaucrat in Egypt's Middle Kingdom, or a soldier in the Persian army, or a farmer in ancient Sumeria. It's not that these ancient societies didn't produce lots of everyday communications.
那个时期的手抄原稿只有几千份幸存下来。至于非常久远的过去，情况简直是一片惨淡。在索福克勒斯写的一百多部戏剧中，我们只得到了七部。但是，越往回追溯，最难找到的，是那些向我们讲述日常生活的文件，讲述埃及中王国时期的一个官僚、波斯军队的一个士兵、或者古代苏美尔的一个农民是什么样的。并不是说这些古代社会没有产生大量日常交流。
Frequently they did. But it's often the most common, ordinary documents that don't survive. Either because no one thought to preserve them, or their society was conquered, or they were written down on a medium that wasn't meant to last. Ask any historian and they'll tell you it's called ephemera for a reason. But today I'm here to tell you the story of some documents of everyday life that did survive. That's 99PI producer Joe Rosenberg. So Joe, you have a story of preservation for us. Yeah. And it's about a trove, you might say, found in what is now northern Iraq of some very, very, very old texts. Very, very, very old times three. That's right. Old times three. And also very, very, very important to historians
通常它们是有的。但往往是最常见、最普通的文献没有留存下来。要么是因为没有人想到要去保护它们，要么是他们的社会被征服了，要么它们被写在一种注定无法持久的媒介上。随便问一个历史学家，他们都会告诉你，被称为“速朽文献”（ephemera）是有原因的。但今天我来这里是要给你们讲一些幸存下来的日常生活文件的故事。那是 99PI 的制作人乔·罗森伯格。所以乔，你为我们准备了一个关于保存的故事。是的。你可以说，这是一批在现在伊拉克北部发现的非常、非常、非常古老的文本宝藏。非常、非常、非常古老，乘以三。没错。古老乘以三。而且对历史学家来说也非常、非常、非常重要
because Iraq, Mesopotamia, is famously where the first ever city-states arose. But for the longest time, historians knew almost nothing about them. This society had been lost to our memory, really. Lisa Wilhelmi is an assistant professor at the Free University of Berlin, who has studied a lot of ancient history, including ancient Mesopotamia.
因为伊拉克，即美索不达米亚，是众所周知的最早的城市国家兴起的地方。但很长一段时间里，历史学家对它们几乎一无所知。这个社会实际上已经从我们的记忆中消失了。丽莎·威廉米是柏林自由大学的助理教授，她研究过很多古代历史，包括古代美索不达米亚。
And she says that until relatively recently, historians might have been able to tell you a lot about the Mesopotamian region, going back to roughly 2,500 years ago, around the time of the ancient Greeks. But if you tried to learn about what happened before then, in these even more ancient places like Babylon and Sumer, there was very little to go on.
她表示，直到相对最近的时候，历史学家或许还能向你讲述很多关于美索不达米亚地区的信息，时间可以追溯到大约 2500 年前，也就是古希腊时期左右。但是，如果你试图了解在此之前发生了什么，在巴比伦和苏美尔这些更古老的地方，可供参考的资料非常少。
It was always there in the ground, but it had been forgotten about to a large extent. And for a very long time, the only references to Assyria and Babylonia came through the Bible. Pete I can sense a problem with using the Bible, which uses a mix of history and mythology as a source text. Jared Yeah, I mean, there was a long period of the study of history where people were just endlessly playing precisely that game of like, which parts of the Bible are true? But there was a moment when this kind of profound veil
它一直都在地下，但在很大程度上已经被遗忘了。在很长一段时间里，关于亚述和巴比伦的唯一参考资料都来自《圣经》。皮特，我能感觉到使用《圣经》作为一个源文本存在一个问题，它混合了历史和神话。贾里德，我的意思是，有很长一段时间的历史研究中，人们只是在无休止地玩这样一个精确的游戏，即《圣经》的哪些部分是真的？但就在某个时刻，这种对深邃古代历史的深刻无知之幕开始被揭开，当时考古学家开始发掘尼尼微城。
of ignorance of the deep ancient past began to be lifted, which is when archeologists began excavating the city of Nineveh. Nineveh was the capital of one of those mysterious biblical empires from around 600 BCE, 2500 years ago, the Neo-Assyrian Empire. But in the 1840s, archaeologists, they actually hit the mother lode, the Assyrians Imperial Palace complex. And once there, they started coming across this huge stash of clay tablets. So first hundreds and then thousands and then tens of thousands of clay tablets and fragments of clay tablets.
尼尼微是大约公元前 600 年、即 2500 年前那些神秘的《圣经》帝国之一——新亚述帝国的首都。但在 19 世纪 40 年代，考古学家们实际上发现了宝库，即亚述帝国宫殿建筑群。一旦到达那里，他们就开始遇到这批巨大的泥板藏品。首先是数百块，然后是数千块，接着是数万块泥板以及泥板碎片。
Wow. And these 2,500 year old tablets, for reasons that we'll get to a little later, are in startlingly great condition. They're all remarkably well preserved. So this find has both quantity and quality going for it. Correct. And even today, if you study ancient Mesopotamia, this find remains arguably the single most impressive collection of documents ever found. It is outstanding. It is extraordinary because there are so many tablets. As far as I know, we have about 30,000 tablets and fragments that we can assign to the collection. And this is really this is a lot.
哇。而这批已有 2500 年历史的泥板，由于我们稍后会讲到的原因，处于惊人的极佳状态。它们都保存得非常完好。所以这次发现既有数量又有质量。没错。甚至在今天，如果你研究古代美索不达米亚，这一发现可以说是迄今为止发现的最令人印象深刻的单一文献收藏。它太杰出了。它是非同寻常的，因为有这么多的泥板。据我所知，我们可以归入这个收藏的泥板和碎片大约有 30,000 块。这真的，这真的是数量巨大。
can assign to the collection. And this is really, this is a lot. And what Lisa says is that it's actually the only ancient tablet collection they speak of as a library. And that's because that is precisely what it turned out to be. This was the Assyrians' official imperial library. And so when you say library,
可以归入这个收藏。而这真的是，这真的是数量巨大。丽莎所说的是，实际上这是唯一一个被他们称为图书馆的古代泥板收藏。那是因为这恰好就是它最终呈现出来的样子。这是亚述人的官方皇家图书馆。所以当你提到图书馆时，
what do you mean in this case? Like, are there ancient works of literature? Or are there sort of textbooks? What does it contain? Yes and yes. Okay. So there are works of literature, mythology, history, astronomy, and not only does it have all the Assyrian stuff from like the seventh century BCE, it's got stuff going back another 1400 years.
在这种情况下你指的是什么？比如，这里有古代文学作品吗？还是说有一些教科书之类的东西？它包含什么？两个都是，是的。好吧。所以这里有文学、神话、历史、天文学作品，而且它不仅拥有所有公元前七世纪左右的亚述资料，它还拥有可以追溯到另外 1400 年前的资料。
Wow. Yeah. So like this is where we, and I mean like the global we here, first found a copy of the Sumerian epic of Gilgamesh. Oh my god. So like possibly the world's oldest written long form narrative was first found here. Yeah, it was. But what over time has turned out to be equally or if you know, not more fascinating in some
哇。是的，所以这就是我们——这里我指的是全球意义上的我们——第一次找到苏美尔史诗《吉尔伽美什》抄本的地方。天哪。所以这可能是有史以来世界上最古老的书面长篇叙事作品，最早就是在这里发现的。是的，确实如此。但随着时间的推移，在某些方面变得同样迷人，或者如果你知道的话，
ways are the library's other documents. Another time has turned out to be equally, or if not more fascinating in some ways, are the library's other documents. Because it turned out that the library also contained all these much more prosaic texts that by virtue of their banality almost, kind of reveal the ins and outs of everyday life. Wow. So what kind of everyday documents, what kind of ephemera are we talking about here? Yeah, so it just so happened that this library included the daily personal correspondence of the Assyrian court. So all of the petitions from ordinary people, all of the letters between scribes, and most
甚至在某些方面更加迷人的，是图书馆的其他文件。随着时间的推移，同样迷人、甚至在某些方面更加迷人的，是图书馆的其他文件。因为事实证明，这座图书馆还包含所有这些更加平淡的文本，由于它们的平庸，它们几乎揭示了日常生活的内幕。哇。那么我们在这里谈论的是什么样的日常文件，什么样的速朽文献呢？是的，巧合的是，这座图书馆里保存了亚述宫廷的日常私人通信。所以所有来自普通人的请愿书，抄写员之间的所有信件，以及对我们的故事来说最
important for our story, messages being written to and from the king. Oh, I see. So everyday royal life. Yes, everyday, but maybe not common. But what that means is that these letters tell the story of the library itself. They tell the story of its creation and its growth right up to the moment before its destruction and unexpected preservation. Wow. So tell me that story.
重要的是写给国王以及国王回复的信件。哦，我明白了。所以是日常的皇家生活。是的，日常的，但也许并不普通。但这意味着这些信件讲述了图书馆本身的故事。它们讲述了它的创建和成长过程，一直讲到它被毁灭和意外保存之前的那一刻。哇。那么请告诉我这个故事。
Like how did it unfold? Let me take you to a precise year. It's the year 671 BCE. And at this time, the Assyrian Empire basically covers most of the present day Middle East. It is by many measures the largest single empire the world has ever seen. And the Assyrians capital is, as mentioned, Nineveh,
比如它是如何展开的？让我带你回到一个确切的年份。那是公元前 671 年。在那个时候，亚述帝国基本上覆盖了当今中东的大部分地区。以许多标准来衡量，它是世界上有史以来最大的单一帝国。正如前面所提到的，亚述帝国的首都是尼尼微，
this great walled city on the banks of the Tigris River. And also, and this is really important to keep in mind, the Assyrians have a reputation for being incessantly, ridiculously, over the top, cruel. So they love in the chronicles to say, oh, I crossed this river on a bridge made at the skulls of my enemy, for example. That'd be fairly typical Assyrian comment.
这座位于底格里斯河畔的伟大宏伟城墙城市。而且还有一点——这在脑海中非常重要——亚述人有着不断地、荒谬地、过分地残酷的名声。所以他们喜欢在编年史里说，哦，比如我用敌人的头骨做成的桥梁跨过了这条河。这会是相当典型的亚述人的评论。
This is David Damrosch. David is a professor of comparative literature at Harvard. And he told me that the Assyrians palaces actually would have these giant images of conquest etched into all the walls. They were meant to intimidate anyone who came into the palace, particularly any foreigner. They'd say just images of tribute being given by everyone who's been conquered. Although Lisa is quick to point out that you should not make the mistake of thinking the Assyrians are uniquely cruel by the standards of their time. I wouldn't say that the Assyrians were more cruel than the other ones.
这是大卫·丹姆罗什。大卫是哈佛大学的比较文学教授。他告诉我，亚述人的宫殿实际上在所有的墙壁上都刻有这些巨大的征服图像。它们旨在威吓任何进入宫殿的人，尤其是任何外国人。他们会展示被征服的每个人所进贡的图像。尽管丽莎很快指出，你不应该犯这样的错误，即认为按他们那个时代的标准来看，亚述人是独一无二的残酷。我不会说亚述人比其他人更残酷。
The Babylonians were just as bad. They just didn't write about it. So the Assyrians were kind of proud of their cruelty and maybe The Babylonians were just as bad. They just didn't write about it. So the Assyrians were kind of proud of their cruelty and maybe the Babylonians were a little more sheepish. Yeah, exactly. Whether it's better to be honest about it or sheepish and hypocritical, I suppose, that's just a matter of taste. But this cruelty, keep in mind, did serve a purpose. David says you have to think of those palace reliefs as a look that the Assyrians were consciously cultivating for strategic reasons. The Assyrians, because of the
巴比伦人同样糟糕。他们只是没有把这些写下来。所以亚述人对他们的残酷有点骄傲，也许巴比伦人也同样糟糕。他们只是没有把这些写下来。所以亚述人对他们的残酷有点骄傲，也许巴比伦人有点害羞。是的，完全是这样。不管是对它诚实更好，还是害羞虚伪更好，我想，这只是一个口味问题。但是请记住，这种残酷确实达到了某种目的。大卫说，你必须将这些宫殿浮雕视为亚述人出于战略原因刻意营造的一种面貌。亚述人由于他们的
way they'd set up their whole economy, were truly a militaristic state and the state really required constant warfare to bring in more goods. So they wanted to project an image of almost totalitarian power. And the text that they wrote for publication project infinite power, infinite sagacity on the part of the king, infinite loyalty on the part of the king's ministers. But remember, the tablets that were found also contain the private palace records. And the story they tell is quite different than the image the Assyrians were publicly projecting. Because at this specific moment in history
整个经济建立的方式，确实是一个军国主义国家，而国家确实需要不断地战争来带来源源不断的物资。因此，他们希望投射出一种几乎是极权主义力量的形象。他们为出版而写的文本投射出无限的力量，国王的无限睿智，国王大臣们的无限忠诚。但请记住，所发现的泥板还包含私人的宫殿记录。他们讲述的故事与亚述人公开投射的形象截然不同。因为在历史上的这个特定时刻，
we've gone back to here, there's a king named Eserhaddon. And it turns out that the all-powerful Eserhaddon was almost hilariously neurotic. BOWEN His DMs reveal a different king than what was presented out front. Yeah, and that's putting it mildly. Eserhaddon was terminally indecisive, and he was also the most powerful person in the world, but he worries about everything.
我们回到了这里，有一位国王名叫阿萨尔哈顿（Esarhaddon）。事实证明，这位全能的阿萨尔哈顿几乎可以说是滑稽地神经质。BOWEN 他的私信揭示了一个与正面形象不同的国王。是的，而且这还是轻描淡写。阿萨尔哈顿有绝症般的优柔寡断，他同时也是世界上权力最大的人，但他对每件事都忧心忡忡。
So just to give you the flavor of Eserhaddon, David told me about this one letter he writes to his chief scribe, where basically Esarhaddon was getting ready to invade yet another country. But then when he was exiting the palace, a mongoose apparently passed under his chariot. I hate it when that happens. I know, it's the worst. And apparently this one little thing is enough to totally freak him out because he immediately starts asking his chief priest, what could this mean? Because, you know, I've heard it said that a mongoose passing under your legs is a bad omen. So maybe we shouldn't invade. Then again, technically the mongoose
所以为了让你体会一下阿萨尔哈顿的性格，大卫跟我讲了他写给首席书记官的一封信，信中基本上是阿萨尔哈顿正准备入侵另一个国家。但随后当他离开宫殿时，一只猫鼬（mongoose）显然从他的战车底下跑了过去。我讨厌发生这种事。我知道，这太糟糕了。显然，这件小小的事就足以让他彻底抓狂，因为他立刻开始问他的大祭司，这可能意味着什么？因为，你知道，我听说过这样一种说法，猫鼬从你的双腿下跑过是一个不祥之兆。所以也许我们不应该入侵。话又说回来，严格来说是猫鼬
passing under my chariot, not my legs. So maybe it's okay. I don't know what to do now. What do you think? And the advisor writes back, and this is from the actual tablet, quote, as to what my Lord the king wrote to me, does the omen, if something passes between the legs of a man, apply to something that came out from underneath the chariot? It does apply. However, he goes on to say that Eserhaddon has it all backwards and not to worry because this is actually a bad omen for his enemies. Quote, so should we say mercy for the Nabataeans? Why? Are they not hostile kings? They will not submit beneath my Lord the King's chariot.
从我的战车下跑过，而不是从我的双腿下。所以也许没关系。我现在不知道该怎么办了。你觉得呢？谋士回信了，这段引自实际的泥板，原话是：“关于我主国王写给我的信，如果有什么东西从一个男人的双腿之间穿过，这个预兆是否适用于从战车底下出来的东西？它确实适用。”然而，他接着说阿萨尔哈顿完全搞反了，不用担心，因为这实际上对他敌人来说是个不祥之兆。原话是：“那么我们应该对纳巴泰人表现出仁慈吗？为什么？他们难道不是敌对的国王吗？他们不会在我主国王的战车下屈服的。”
And this letter is basically par for the course for Esarhaddon. His whole reign was pretty much him endlessly overinterpreting omens. And Esarhaddon, if lightning strikes a distant town, Esarhaddon takes it personally. He writes a letter to one of his advisors who writes back, "'As to what my lord the king wrote to me,
这封信基本上是阿萨尔哈顿的常态。他的整个统治时期几乎都是他在无休止地过度解读征兆。而且阿萨尔哈顿，如果闪电击中了一个遥远的城镇，阿萨尔哈顿会把它当成针对他个人的事。他写信给他的一个顾问，顾问回信道：“至于我主国王写给我的信，
"'why does the king look for trouble? "'Why does he look for a peasant's hut? "'There's no evil inside the palace. "'And when has the king ever visited that town?' So the poor advisors, you know, nothing escapes the king's worry. I mean, the advisor is actually surprisingly blunt with the most powerful man in the entire known world.
‘为什么国王要自找麻烦？’‘为什么他要关注一个农民的小屋？’‘宫殿里没有什么邪恶。’‘而且国王什么时候访问过那个城镇？’”所以可怜的顾问们，你知道的，没有什么能逃过国王的担忧。我的意思是，这位顾问对整个已知世界上权力最大的人实际上出奇地直言不讳。
Yeah, it's true. And we actually know that the advisor who wrote that last one was a guy named Blossie, who clearly was one of the few people who can speak this frankly with the king. And his letters to him appear to grow more and more impatient. So, for example, at another point, there's this minor earthquake, apparently, which sends Eserhaddon into one of his spirals. And now, Bilassi replies in tones of complete exasperation.
是的，确实如此。我们实际上知道写下最后那封信的顾问是一个名叫布拉西（Blassie）的人，他显然是极少数能够对国王如此直言不讳的人之一。他写给国王的信似乎变得越来越不耐烦。例如，在另一个时刻，显然发生了一场小地震，这让阿萨尔哈顿陷入了又一次的抓狂漩涡中。现在，布拉西用彻底气急败坏的语气回复了。
Was there no earthquake in the times of the king's fathers and grandfathers? Did I not see earthquakes when I was small? And you see his advisors writing to each other saying, Why is the king like this? What can we do? Why is he so worried about an earthquake in the south of the country? How can we stop this? How can we reassure him?
在国王的父亲和祖父的时代难道没有发生过地震吗？当我小的时候难道没有见过地震吗？你看到他的顾问们互相写信说，为什么国王会这样？我们能做些什么？为什么他这么担心国家南部的地震？我们如何才能阻止这一点？我们如何才能让他安心？
I mean, the level of detail here is just amazing. Like these are exchanges between people that are 2,500 years old. And you really feel like you're getting a window into like an unhealthy level of neuroses and paranoia from Aserhadon, which was of course bad for him, but potentially devastating to everyone around him. Yes, although in his defense,
我的意思是，这里的细节丰富程度简直太惊人了。就像这些是彼此相距 2500 年的人之间的交流。你真的会觉得你打开了一扇窗户，看到了来自阿萨尔哈顿的不健康的神经质和偏执程度，这对他自己来说当然是糟糕的，但对周围的每个人来说可能是毁灭性的。是的，不过为他辩护一下，
like a lot of pathologically neurotic people, he's not being totally illogical either, in his case when it comes to worrying about omens. Because Lisa says that you have to understand that back then, no matter what you believed, the stakes around omens were Lisa says that you have to understand that back then no matter what you believed the stakes around omens were really high. If you live in a world where everything is influenced by the divine and there is no question as to the involvement of divinity in what happens on earth then the Omen literature and the divination and its processes are very, they're political.
就像许多病态神经质的人一样，他也并非完全不合逻辑，就他担心征兆而言。因为丽莎说，你必须明白，在那个时候，无论你信仰什么，关于征兆的利害关系丽莎说，你必须明白，在那个时候，无论你信仰什么，关于征兆的利害关系都是非常高的。如果你生活在一个一切都受神圣影响的世界里，并且对于神灵对地球上发生的事情的参与没有任何疑问，那么征兆文献、占卜及其过程是非常、非常具有政治性的。
They are what drives politics. Oh, I see. So there wasn't really an option to ignore omens, even if you wanted to. Correct. And another part of Eser Haddon's problem is he himself, as a boy, grew up in a time of plots and counter plots and splinter groups. You know, his own father was killed by one of his brothers in a coup. But ultimately for Eserhaddon, all of these considerations only drive him, you know, deeper into his neuroses. And he just grows increasingly and really illogically suspicious
它们正是驱动政治的东西。哦，我明白了。所以实际上没有选择忽视征兆的余地，即使你想这样做。没错。阿萨尔哈顿的另一个问题是，他自己作为男孩，是在一个充满阴谋、反阴谋和分裂集团的时期长大的。你知道的，他自己的亲生父亲就在一次政变中被他的一个兄弟杀害了。但对阿萨尔哈顿来说，所有这些考量最终只会把他推向，你知道的，更深的神经质中。他对轨道内的基本上每一个人都变得越来越怀疑，而且确实是不合逻辑地怀疑。
of basically every person in his orbit. So in addition to obsessing over omens, he is also commissioning multiple independent oracles and cross-checking the results so the gods can tell him who on his staff might be betraying him. And the small print on Eserhaddon's oracle requests, it's just wild. So here, I just want you to read this one. Okay. Shamash, great lord, give me a definitive answer to what I ask you. Will any of the eunuchs or the bearded officials, the king's entourage or any of his brothers and uncles or junior members of the royal line or any relative of the king whatever
因此，除了痴迷于征兆之外，他还委托多个独立的灵媒进行神谕占卜，并交叉核对结果，以便神灵可以告诉他，他手下的哪个人可能在背叛他。而阿萨尔哈顿神谕请求上的小字，简直太疯狂了。所以在这里，我只想让你读这一段。好吧。沙马什，伟大的主，请给我一个明确的回答，回答我所问的事。任何太监或蓄须的官员、国王的随从、或他的任何兄弟和叔叔、或王室的年轻成员、或国王的任何亲戚、
or the prefects or the recruitment officers or his personal guard or the king's chariot men or the keepers of the inner gates or the keepers of the inner gates, or the keepers of the outer gates, or the attendants and lackeys of the stables, or the cooks, confectioners, and bakers, the entire body of craftsmen, or their brothers, or their sons, or their nephews, or their friends, or their guests, or their accomplices, make an uprising and rebellion against Aserhadon, king of Assyria, and kill him? That's a long list of people he does not trust. Yeah, I mean, although I still don't know why he has to list everyone specifically. He could just ask, will anyone betray me? That seems easy.
或是省长、或征兵官、或他的私人卫队、或国王的战车手、或内城门的看守、或内城门的看守、或外城门的看守、或马厩的侍从和随从、或厨师、糖果糕点师和面包师、整个工匠群体、或者他们的兄弟、或者他们的儿子、或者他们的侄子、或者他们的朋友、或者他们的客人、或者他们的同谋，会向亚述国王阿萨尔哈顿发动暴动和叛乱并杀死他吗？这是一长串他不信任的人。是的，我的意思是，虽然我仍然不知道为什么他必须具体列出每个人。他可以只问，有人会背叛我吗？这似乎很容易。
I mean, his writing is done in clay. You should economize your words a little bit. Yeah, although it's interesting that you're picturing him doing the writing, because actually that brings us to what was arguably Eserhadon's biggest problem when it came to his paranoia, which was that he may have spent all day sending these messages back and forth, but, and this will be key to the story of the library, Eserhadon himself didn't know how to read. Oh, interesting. Okay. Yeah, because apparently reading and writing,
我的意思是，他的文字是用泥土写的。你应该稍微节省一点字数。是的，尽管有趣的是，你把想象中的他写字的情景画了出来，但实际上这引出了阿萨尔哈顿在偏执方面可以说是最大的问题，那就是他可能一整天都在发送这些来回的消息，但是——这将是图书馆故事的关键——阿萨尔哈顿自己并不识字。哦，有趣。好吧。是的，因为显然阅读和写作，
particularly cuneiform, was kind of like coding today. You know, it was a real skill. So most kings just dictated letters and had letters read to them. They weren't doing any reading or writing themselves. But this meant that they were relying on whoever's advising them to tell them what is happening. And what's clear from these tablets
特别是楔形文字，有点像今天的编程。你知道的，这真是一门技术。所以大多数国王只是口述信件并让人把信读给他们听。他们自己不做任何阅读或写作。但这意味著他们依赖任何建议他们的人来告诉他们正在发生什么。而从这些泥板中明显可以看出，
is that the readers maybe didn't always read everything on the tablet out loud to the king. In one case, an out of favor official writes an appeal to the king, but he knows the king isn't gonna read it. And he has a little postscript to his appeal. Whoever you are, O scribe, who are reading this, do not hide it from your Lord the King.
这些朗读者可能并不总是把泥板上的所有内容都大声读给国王听。在一个案例中，一个失宠的官员向国王写了一份申诉，但他知道国王不会读它。他在他的申诉后面有一个小后记。无论你是谁，哦，抄作家，正在阅读这个，不要向你的主国王隐瞒。
Speak for me before the King." So it's quite a fascinating thing. They all know that there are these intermediaries who are extremely powerful. They can be powerful simply by what they don't say is on the tablet. I mean, that is amazing that the advisors and the intermediaries, they're the ones with the real power. Like they could just choose to not read part of the letter, to make up something completely and the king would be none the wiser. Right, yeah. And from what historians can piece together, it appears that Asher had on very wisely reasoned, you know what? Being illiterate sucks. So my son will learn to read.
在国王面前为我说话。”所以这是一件非常着迷的事情。他们都知道有这些极其强大的中间人。他们可以通过不说什么在泥板上来变得强大。我的意思是，这太神奇了，顾问和中间人，他们才是真正拥有权力的人。就像他们可以只选择不读信的一部分，完全编造一些东西，而国王却被蒙在鼓里。对，是的。根据历史学家所能拼凑的信息，阿萨尔哈顿非常明智地推理出，你知道吗？文盲太糟糕了。所以我的儿子将学会读书。
That's an excellent idea. Fantastic idea. And his son's name is Asher Banipal. And Ashurbanipal is in many ways the reason why there would be a great library for archaeologists to discover in the first place. Because he is a totally different breed of person from his father. And he becomes one of the great Assyrian kings. He's known for many things. And true to his father's wishes, David says that from an early age, Ashurbanipal not only learned to read, but he loved to read.
这是一个极好的主意。绝妙的主意。他的儿子的名字叫亚述巴尼拔（Ashurbanipal）。在很多方面，亚述巴尼拔正是考古学家最终能够发现一座伟大图书馆的原因。因为他与他的父亲是完全不同类型的人。他成为了亚述伟大的国王之一。他以许多事情而闻名。正如他父亲的愿望一样，大卫说，从小到大，亚述巴尼拔不仅学会了阅读，而且他热爱阅读。
I think he was really a bibliophile, you know, or a tabletophile, whatever you have to call it. He just loved writing. He was fascinated by it. He was proud of his abilities of being what we would later say is a kind of philosopher king. And the thing to understand is that prior to Ashurbanipal, the palace archive only really contained the everyday correspondence, the court records, which is how we know so much about his dad. But once Ashurbanipal is in power, he takes the existing archive and starts expanding it
我想他真的是个藏书狂，你知道的，或者叫泥板狂，随便你怎么称呼它。他就是喜欢写作。他对此着迷。他为自己具备后来我们所说的“哲学王”的能力感到自豪。需要理解的是，在亚述巴尼拔之前，宫殿档案库其实只包含日常信件、宫廷记录，这就是为什么我们对他的父亲了解这么多的原因。但一旦亚述巴尼拔掌权，他就将现有的档案库扩大，并开始将其扩展
into what we would think of as a proper library. And this library gets big. He actually creates two new palace buildings just to house it. And he uses the size and power of his empire to collect everything he can get his hands on and expand the collection. And not just the numbers of texts, but the kinds of texts. So old Sumerian and Babylonian literature, let's get that.
为我们所认为的正规图书馆。这个图书馆变得越来越大。他实际上建造了两个新的宫殿建筑来容纳它。他利用其帝国的规模和力量来收集他所能触及的一切并扩大馆藏。不仅是文本的数量，还有文本的种类。因此，古苏美尔和巴比伦文学，让我们得到它。
Astronomy texts, great. Writings on statecraft, yes, let's add that too. Particularly interesting is that Ashurbanipal sends out a word to scribes all around the kingdom saying, if you know any texts about good government, send it to me. And that's one of the times he gets a new copy made of Gilgamesh. He was reading it as a tale about how to understand what makes a good ruler and a bad ruler
天文学文本，太棒了。关于治国方略的著作，是的，也把这些加进去。特别有趣的是，亚述巴尼拔向王国各地的抄写员发出消息说，如果你知道任何关于良好政府的文本，请把它发给我。这也是他获得了一份新的《吉尔伽美什》抄本的时期之一。他把它读作一个关于如何理解是什么造就了一个好统治者和一个坏统治者、
and how to be better. And so the collection actually ends up with multiple copies of Gilgamesh. And a little later, it actually acquires a record showing the astronomical positions of Venus, you know, going back to at least 1700 BCE. And there's an even older Babylonian text, which is the only complete surviving account of an ancient Near Eastern creation myth. Wow.
以及如何变得更好的故事。因此，这个收藏最终确实有了多个《吉尔伽美什》的副本。稍后，它实际上获得了一份记录，展示了金星的天文位置，你知道的，可以追溯到至少公元前 1700 年。还有一个更古老的巴比伦文本，它是古代近东创世神话的唯一完整幸存记录。哇。
And so that's on top of all this day-to-day minutiae of past kings and their courts, and you have that as a reference. So it's kind of like having the Library of Congress and a presidential library and a national archive kind of all rolled into one. Pretty much, yeah. Which is why, if I could show you one final thing from the collection, this library also contains Asher Banipal's own writings. And one of the things he wrote was poetry.
所以这不仅叠加了过去国王及其宫廷的所有日常琐事，你还将此作为参考。所以这有点像把美国国会图书馆、总统图书馆和国家档案馆合三为一。差不多，是的。这就是为什么，如果我可以向你展示收藏中的最后一件东西，这个图书馆还包含亚述巴尼拔自己的著作。他写的东西之一就是诗歌。
And there's this one poem where he's actually addressing the patron god of writing, Naboo. And it's just incredibly intimate. You can almost hear in it how he has inherited some of his father's depression and anxiety, but he's kind of channeling it through his writing. So Roman, if you wanna just give this one a read too. Okay.
有一首诗，他实际上在向写作的守护神纳布（Nabu）倾诉。它是如此的难以置信的亲密。你几乎可以从中听到他是如何继承了他父亲的一些抑郁和焦虑，但他某种程度上通过他的写作将其引导出来。所以罗曼，如果你也想把这个读一下。好吧。
Often I go up to the roof in order to plunge down, but my life is too precious. It turns me back. I would hearten myself, but what heart do I have to give? I would make up my mind. But what mind do I have to make up? Oh Nabu, where is your forgiveness? Oh, son of Belle, where is your guidance?
我常常走上屋顶打算跳下去，但我的人生太珍贵了。它把我拉了回来。我想鼓舞自己，但我有什么心可以付出？我想下定决心。但我有什么决心可以下定？哦，纳布，你的宽恕在哪里？哦，贝尔之子，你的指引在哪里？
Wow. Heavy as the head. I mean, was this written down just for himself or was this meant to be taken in by a wider audience? Was this for posterity? I was curious about that too and I asked David about it and he said that the answer is likely the latter. It was probably at least semi-propaganda because in the very next stanza, Ashurbanipal says that the god Naboo comes to him in a dream and basically tells him, don't worry, you
哇。欲戴其冠，必承其重。我的意思是，这仅仅是为他自己写下来的，还是打算让更广泛的受众看到？这是为了后世吗？我也对此感到好奇，我问了大卫，他说答案很可能是后者。这可能至少是半个宣传，因为在接下来的诗节中，亚述巴尼拔说神纳布在梦中找到了他，并基本上告诉他，不要担心，你
will emerge triumphant and your ill-wishers will be squashed under your feet like flies. So even the sensitive poet who contemplates jumping off the tallest tower still builds bridges out of the skulls of his enemies. Yeah, there doesn't really seem to be an off button for that kind of thing when it comes to these Assyrian kings. And so Ashurbanipal simply continued his kingdom's policy of unending military expansion.
将凯旋而出，你的恶毒之敌将像苍蝇一样被踩在你的脚下。因此，即使是那个考虑从最高塔上跳下来的敏感诗人，仍然用他敌人的头骨建造桥梁。是的，对于这些亚述国王来说，这种事情似乎真的没有关闭按钮。因此，亚述巴尼拔只是简单地继续他王国的无休止军事扩张政策。
And I asked David about that too, about his double nature. Do you like Ashurbanipal at all or not? Like, where do you come across in your own personal take on these figures. No, I think, I think Ashurbanipal is a wonderful figure, thoughtful, reflective, he's trying to do his best. He is a poet and he's responsible for a vicious militaristic system
我也问过大卫关于这一点，关于他的双重性质。你到底喜不喜欢亚述巴尼拔？就像，你对这些人物的个人看法是什么。不，我想，我认为亚述巴尼拔是一个极好的人物，深思熟虑，反思，他正在尽最大努力。他是一位诗人，他负责一个残酷的军国主义制度，
that is not likely to last, that he has to uphold. And I think that's why Ashurbanipal's feeling has his suicidal moments. It's like, how long can this hold together? And that turns out to be pretty much true. I mean, the relentless expansionist system can't last. And after Ashurbanipal dies, everything kind of starts to fall apart.
这是不太可能持久的，但他必须维护。我想这就是为什么亚述巴尼拔会有自杀时刻的感觉。就像，这能维持多久？事实证明这几乎是真的。我的意思是，无情的扩张主义体制无法持久。在亚述巴尼拔死后，一切都开始分崩离析。
All the states who the Assyrians conquered understandably loathed them. And in 612 BC, the vassal states all band together to revolt and then sack and raze Nineveh, the Assyrian capital, and burn all of it, including Ashurbanipal's library to the ground. So if that's the case, then how did the library get preserved? So this is the final puzzle piece of this story. And it's where one of the great oddities
所有被亚述人征服的国家都理所当然地痛恨他们。公元前 612 年，附属国们联合起来起义，然后洗劫并夷为平地了亚述首都尼尼微，烧毁了一切，包括亚述巴尼拔的图书馆化为灰烬。如果是这样的话，那么图书馆是如何被保存下来的呢？所以这是这个故事的最后一块拼图。这就是历史保护的一大奇特之处
of historical preservation comes in. Because ironically, one of the best things that can happen for the preservation of your society's legacy is basically a sudden terrible cataclysm that entombs everything you know and love in an instant and leaves it forgotten for thousands of years. Cataclysmic entombs everything you know and love in an instant and leaves it forgotten for thousands of years. Cataclysmic destruction is terrible for society, but it can be really good, because then what's left there may just get left.
发挥作用的地方。因为具有讽刺意味的是，对保护你社会的遗产最好的事情之一，基本上是一场突然的、可怕的灾难，它在瞬间将你所知道和喜爱的一切都埋葬在地下，并让它被遗忘了数千年。灾难性的毁灭将你所知道和热爱的一切都在瞬间埋葬，并让它被遗忘了数千年。灾难性的毁灭对社会来说是可怕的，但它可能真的很好，因为那样留在那里地东西可能就会被原封不动地留下。
I mean, this reminds me of like Pompeii, where, you know, the eruption of Mount Vesuvius, like, covers everything in ash, and you get this snapshot of, you know, things as mundane as what kind of snacks people were eating that food cart owners were selling in just like an incredible catastrophe that just sort of just freezes everything in time. Exactly, which is why that kind of instant catastrophe is often, you know, in a weird way, what counts as good news for historians like Lisa. Yeah, no, accidental destruction tends to preserve much more information on the actual lives of people. All of the letters, all of the accounts, all of the debt notes. And then we get the real people, their imagination, their stories. So in the case of Nineveh, how did the tablets get preserved before the invaders ransacked the place?
我的意思是，这让我想起了庞贝古城，你知道的，维苏威火山的爆发，比如，用火山灰覆盖了一切，你会得到这样一个快照，你知道的，关于人们在吃什么零食、食品车老板在卖什么的琐事，在一场令人难以置信的灾难中，它只是把一切都冻结在时间里。绝对如此，这就是为什么那种瞬间的灾难通常，用一种奇怪的方式，对像丽莎这样的历史学家来说算是好消息。是的，不，意外的破坏往往会保留更多关于人们实际生活的信件、所有的账目、所有的债务票据。然后我们得到了真实的、他们想象中的人们，他们的故事。所以在尼尼微的例子中，在侵略者洗劫这个地方之前，泥板是如何被保存下来的？
Because I can't imagine they were like, would be careful with the clay tablets in the library. No, so with Nineveh, weirdly, it was precisely because the invaders set fire to the library buildings that the tablets were preserved. Because remember, all of these tablets were made of clay. And these tablets fill through the floor into the basement and were buried in the rubble. But the thing with with canary firm tablets is if you cook them, it makes them last forever.
因为我无法想象他们会像这样，在图书馆里小心对待泥板。不，所以在尼尼微，奇怪的是，正是因为入侵者放火烧毁了图书馆建筑，这些泥板才得以保存。因为记住，所有这些泥板都是用泥土制成的。这些泥板穿过地板落入地下室，并被埋在废墟中。但楔形文字泥板的事情是，如果你烤它们，它们就会永远保存下去。
They become like terracotta. And so the tens of thousands of terracottaized tablets just sit there, buried and preserved for 2,500 years. You know, all the literature and history the Assyrians wanted preserved, but also all the everyday stuff they'd probably be mortified to know was preserved, until 1849 when they were discovered. And so that's how we know all this wonderful history and literature and the story of why it's there in the first place. And one of the things that was part of royal ideology in the ancient Near East was to try and get your name to be preserved for eternity. And in a way, I wouldn't actually say that the effort failed because here we are two and a half thousand years later,
它们变得像兵马俑一样。于是，数以万计的被陶器化了的泥板就那样静静地躺在那里，被掩埋并保存了 2500 年。你知道的，亚述人希望保存的所有文学和历史，以及所有他们可能因被保存下来而感到羞耻的日常生活琐事，直到 1849 年它们被发现。这就是我们如何了解所有这些精彩的历史和文学，以及它为什么会在那里的故事。古代近东皇家意识形态的一部分，就是试图让你的名字流芳百世。从某种意义上说，我实际上不会说这种努力失败了，因为我们现在在这里，在两千五百年后，
speaking about it. I mean, it's just remarkable that it took both things. Like, it took the act of creation of the library and its destruction for all this knowledge to be preserved for us to take it in 2,500 years later. Like, if only one of those things had happened, we wouldn't be talking about this. We would never know that name.
谈论它。我的意思是，这太了不起了，这两件事缺一不可。就像，需要图书馆的创建行为和它的毁灭，所有这些知识才能为我们所保存，以便我们在 2500 年后吸收它。就像，如果只有其中一件事发生，我们就不会谈论这个。我们永远不会知道那个名字。
We would never know this civilization. It's stunning. Yeah, preserving the human legacy. I mean, it kind of turns out it takes, I guess, equal parts hard work and dumb luck. That's right. That's right. Well said. Well, Joe, thank you so much for this. This is really just this unexpected way to journey back into time. I just loved our conversation. No, thank you, Roman, for listening. I'm glad you enjoyed the journey. When we come back, we'll learn more about how historians succeed and sometimes fail in piecing together all those thousands of ancient fragments.
我们永远不会了解这个文明。太震撼了。是的，保护人类遗产。我的意思是，结果证明，我想，这需要同等部分的辛苦工作和盲目的运气。没错。说得好。乔，非常感谢你带来这些。这确实是回到过去的一种意想不到的方式。我只是太喜欢我们的对话了。不，谢谢罗曼的倾听。我很高兴你喜欢这段旅程。当我们回来时，我们将更多地了解历史学家在拼凑所有数千个古代碎片时如何成功，有时又如何失败。
So Jo, you're back and you have a little antechamber of this archaeological story that you want to talk about. Yeah, I do. Because I have to confess something here, which is that I was being intentionally a little vague when I said Lisa Wahame was a professor who studies ancient history, because Lisa actually wears a few different scholarly hats. And one of them is a very cool job with a very confusing name. She is an Assyriologist. An Assyriologist. So I take it this is someone who studies ancient Assyria.
所以乔，你回来了，你想谈谈这个考古故事的一个小前厅。是的，我确实想。因为我在这里必须坦白一件事，那就是当我故意说丽莎·瓦哈姆是一位研究古代历史的教授时，我其实说的有点含糊，因为丽莎实际上戴着几顶不同的学术帽子。其中之一是一份名字非常混乱但非常酷的工作。她是一位亚述学家（Assyriologist）。亚述学家。所以我想这是一个研究古代亚述的人。
So no. And this is what's confusing because Assyriology is actually the study of any ancient society that used cuneiform writing, whether you're looking at the Sumerians or the Babylonians or the Assyrians or whoever. And your particular focus could be archaeology, it could be art history, et cetera. And in Lisa's case, she spends a lot of time sorting through and interpreting texts. What we do is we look at texts, we try and piece them back together, we then try to understand them chronologically, geographically, and also content-wise. So we get more information on people, society, history, culture, literature, and so on. So really what we do is we have a giant puzzle
所以不是的。这就是令人困惑的地方，因为亚述学实际上是对任何使用楔形文字的古代社会的研​​究，无论你看的是苏美尔人、巴比伦人、亚述人还是其他人。你的具体重点可能是考古学、艺术史等。就丽莎而言，她花了很多时间整理和解释文本。我们所做的是我们查看文本，我们试图将它们重新拼凑在一起，然后我们试图在时间上、地理上以及内容上理解它们。因此，我们获得了关于人、社会、历史、文化、文学等的更多信息。所以实际上我们所做的是我们有一个巨大的拼图
and we try and get more and more pieces, but we try and fill in the gaps. And, you know, although I went into the interview with Lisa intending to ask a bunch of questions about the Assyrians and the Library of Asher Banapal specifically, I really ended up spending the majority of our time talking with her about her profession, because I got really fascinated with the story
我们试图得到越来越多的碎片，但我们试图填补空白。而且，你知道，虽然我带着一堆关于亚述人和亚述巴尼拔图书馆的特定问题去采访丽莎，但我最后确实把大部分时间都花在与她讨论她的职业上，因为我对
of what Lisa does. So not so much the archaeology and the digging up of whatever texts remain, but how Lisa and her colleagues go about putting the pieces of what does remain back together. And that actually starts with the question, which sounds kind of like a Zen Cohen, of how can you know how much has been lost? I was thinking about this, and it's actually impossible to say how much has been lost,
丽莎所做的事情的故事着迷了。所以与其说是考古学和挖掘任何剩余的文本，不如说是丽莎和她的同事如何着手将剩余的东西拼凑回去。这实际上始于一个听起来像禅宗公案的问题：你怎么能知道失去了多少？我想过这个问题，实际上不可能说失去了多少，
I think. And it's funny because invariably how much has been lost, I think. And it's funny because invariably this is one of those things where you can't help but invoke Don Rumsfeld. Yes, that's right. Because you have the known known, you have the known unknown and the unknown unknown, etc. etc. I mean, you know, you'd think his legacy would be the Iraq War and yet in fact it is really this one quote. Almost every day of my life I think about this.
我认为。有趣的是，失去了多少，我想，这总是不可避免地让人联想到唐·拉姆斯费尔德（Don Rumsfeld）。是的，没错。因为你有已知已知，你有已知未知和未知未知，等等，等等。我的意思是，你知道的，你会认为他的遗产将是伊拉克战争，然而事实上这确实是这一句名言。我生命中的几乎每一天我都在想这件事。
That is also how Lisa talks about this. When it comes to the basis of texts, very often we have gaps in our texts. We don't have the whole Gilgamesh epic. We're missing about a third or so of the text. So things keep coming to us and we keep piecing it together, but we don't have it in completion. So in those cases, we know how much we are missing. So that's probably the most straightforward problem, where they know how much they are missing,
这也是丽莎谈论此事的方式。说到文本的基础，我们常常在文本中存在空白。我们没有完整的《吉尔伽美什》史诗。我们丢失了大约三分之一左右的文本。所以事情不断向我们走来，我们不断地把它拼凑起来，但我们并没有完整地拥有它。所以在这些情况下，我们知道我们缺少了多少。所以这可能是最直接的问题，他们知道自己缺少了多少，
but then there's like one stage more complicated than that. So these are things where we know that we are missing something. We don't know exactly how much we are missing. An acute example, for instance, would be the fact that we have references to place names in our texts and we don't know where these places were. They haven't been located yet. And interestingly enough, we also have copies of texts where the text itself says, it writes something
但随后有一个比这更复杂阶段的事情。这些是我们知道我们缺少某些东西的事情。我们不知道确切缺少了多少。例如，一个尖锐的例子是，我们的文本中有对地名的引用，但我们不知道这些地方在哪里。它们还没有被定位。有趣的是，我们也有文本的副本，其中文本本身说，它写了一些
and then it says, chepi, which means broken. So obviously the scribe writing this tablet, found a tablet that he was copying, had some missing bits. So he would either have to get the information from a different copy of the same text or just say, well, actually I don't know. That's so interesting. This isn't just a modern problem. Like tablets way back then were already breaking and scribes were already going, we don't know what follows because something has already gotten broken or lost. It's already gone. Yeah. And it actually gets worse because Lisa
然后上面写着：chepi，意思是损坏。所以很显然，写这个泥板的抄写员发现他正在复制的泥板有一些残缺的部分。因此，他要么必须从同一文本的不同抄本中获取信息，要么只能说，好吧，其实我也不知道。这太有趣了。这不仅仅是一个现代问题。就像当年的泥板已经开始破损，抄写员们就已经在说，我们不知道接下来是什么，因为有些内容已经损坏或丢失了。它已经不见了。是的。而且情况实际上更糟糕，因为丽莎
says that in her particular specialty, which is an ancient society called the Hittites, their preferred medium for everyday writing possibly just completely disappeared. This may have something to do with the fact that particular types of texts might have been written on wood. So we know this because we have... Well, we don't know it for sure because they didn't write down for us actually, attention please people in 2000 years when you read these texts, we also wrote some tablets on wood.
说，在她专门研究的领域，也就是一个名为赫梯人的古代社会中，他们日常书写偏好的载体可能完全消失了。这可能与特定类型的文本可能是写在木头上有关。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为我们有……好吧，我们并不是百分之百确定，因为他们没有给我们留下这样的字条：‘请注意，两千五百年来阅读这些文本的人们，我们也把一些泥板写在了木头上。’
And you will not find these because they won't be preserved. Yeah, because why would that occur to anyone to write that down? If it was just an obvious facet of everyday life that you wrote on wood, you would not bother to remark upon it. Yeah, which, you know, when I heard it kind of made me start to wonder like, what is the really obvious thing we're not telling future historians that might help them out. But that actually brings us to my favorite category of unknowns and the one Rumsfeld famously did not mention, which is, actually, do you wanna guess which one this is?
‘而且你们找不到这些，因为它们无法保存下来。’是的，因为怎么会有人想到把这个写下来呢？如果这只是日常生活中显而易见的一个方面，即你在木头上写字，你就不会费心去评论它。是的，你知道，当我听到这个时，我开始想，到底是什么显而易见的事情是我们没有告诉未来历史学家，而这些事情可能会对他们有所帮助。但这也把我们带到了我最喜欢的未知类别，也就是拉姆斯菲尔德曾著名的没有提及的那一类，实际上，你想猜猜这是哪一类吗？
I guess the unknown knowns. Which are kind of hard to imagine, but. Right, they are the things that you know, but you don't realize you know. Okay. Right? And this is due to the problem that for all that's missing, they actually have way too many fragments in way too many places.
我猜是“未知的已知”。这些其实很难想象，但是。没错，它们是你所知道的，但你并没有意识到你知道的。好吧。对吧？这是由于这样一个问题：尽管缺少了很多东西，但他们在太多地方拥有太多的碎片。
The museums are full of texts that we haven't read yet. There are many, many texts and there are not so many ethereologists or etiologists. So the human resources bit is not really adequate to making quick progress. Is it possible that that one-third of Gilgamesh that's missing is actually just waiting around in a drawer? Absolutely. It will be somewhere. Wow.
博物馆里装满了我们还没读过的文本。有非常多的文本，而亚述学家或楔形文字专家却没那么多。所以人力资源方面其实不足以取得快速进展。吉尔伽美什失踪的三分之一会不会其实正静静地躺在某个抽屉里？绝对会。它肯定在某处。哇。
Probably not all of it because it's bits and pieces within the story that we're missing. But I'm always very hopeful, actually. I think we will get there, but it will just take time. I mean, that's just an amazingly romantic thought. Let the remainder of the world's oldest written long-form narrative is not actually lost forever. That you could have faith that it is surviving somewhere in a drawer. And you may not be alive to see it, but eventually it will be found. Yeah, or at least found before it's all lost again.
可能不全都是，因为我们丢失的是故事中的零星片段。但实际上我一直抱有很大的希望。我想我们会做到的，但这需要时间。我的意思是，这真是一个极其浪漫的想法。世界上最古老的叙事长诗的剩余部分其实并没有永远消失。你可以坚信它正存活在某个抽屉里。你可能活不到看到它的时候，但它最终会被找到。是的，或者至少在它再次全部丢失之前被找到。
Because who knows, because we wrote it down in computer code and future historians will be like, why did they use such a bad medium? I can totally see that being the case. Well, this has really been just incredibly fascinating journey that you brought us on, Joe. I really appreciate it. Thank you so much
因为谁知道呢，因为我们把它写成了计算机代码，未来的历史学家会想：他们为什么使用这么糟糕的载体？我完全能想象会是这样。好吧，乔，这真是一段令人难以置信的迷人旅程，你把我们带到了这里。我真的很感激。非常感谢。
Thank you Roman take care 99% invisible was produced this week by Joe Rosenberg and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald mixed by Martine Gonzalez Music by Swan Real additional music by George Langford fact-checking by Sona of Ockin additional music by George Langford fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Special thanks to our guests this week Lisa Wilhelmi and David Damroche who recorded these interviews with us nearly three years ago and have been waiting patiently ever since. We're especially thankful to David for his book about the Epic of Gilgamesh. It's called The Buried Book which is where we first encountered this story. His newest work is called Around the World in 80 Books.
谢谢罗曼，保重。本周的《99%无形》由乔·罗斯伯格制作，埃met·菲茨杰拉德剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，天鹅交响乐团配乐，乔治·兰格福德提供额外音乐，索娜·奥基安负责事实核查。特别感谢我们本周的嘉宾丽莎·威廉姆和大卫·达姆罗什，他们在近三年前与我们录制了这些采访，并一直耐心等待至今。我们特别感谢大卫关于《吉尔伽美什史诗》的书。它叫《被埋葬的书》，这也是我们第一次接触到这个故事的地方。他的最新作品是《八十本书环游世界》。
You can find both of them wherever books are sold. Kathy Tuer is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berrupe, Jason DeLeon, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lashma Dawn, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars.
你可以在任何出售书籍的地方找到这两本书。凯西·图尔是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什玛·道恩、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。
The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. InBeautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites. I'm on Blue Sky a lot. I like Blue Sky a lot. We also have our own Discord server.
99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们。我在Blue Sky上很活跃。我很喜欢Blue Sky。我们也有自己的Discord服务器。
There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99 PI and 99 PI There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里有一个链接，指向每一期过去的99 PI节目。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。